I want to be where the people are I
wanna hear wanna hear um nitpick I have
been waiting to use that intro for so
friggin long I kept having to bounce
this stuff back so nitpick rant time and
this one hurts to do but I do need to
talk about it because the Little Mermaid
is my nostalgic favorite Disney movie
and that actually depending on how much
you know about me or whether you're
stumbling across this video randomly
should not come as a huge surprise
because given you know my own personal
sense of gender the fact that it doesn't
stay put this has become very well
adopted as a highly functional trans
narrative given Ariel's you know I mean
you know you could say she did it for a
guy Eric was the tipping point really
she is from the beginning she feels like
she belongs in another world
she belongs there she should be
something else than she is and she's
willing to go to some potentially
self-destructive lengths to do that and
even though maybe she didn't go about it
in the best way that still is where she
belongs
it works really well through that
interpretation I seriously got it was
the original intentional interpretation
of the thing but it works really well
and it probably did connect to that part
of me even at a young age and I've
always loved Arielle I love the music
part of your world that were pries
specifically I think is possibly my
favorite Disney song of all time Ursula
is one of the best if not the best
villains I'll do a Disney Villains list
at some point but there is a problem
that I have with this movie and I got to
talk about it and the thing is it
happens towards the very end and I
considered actually filing this under
good movie bad ending
except that I I don't think it sinks the
movie the way that my entries in that
list do but it is a problem so various
people as has often been the case with
Disney Princess movies have brought up
various things that bother them over
time the fact that Ariel is 16 yeah at
this point in time that is a little bit
annoying 18 would have been better and
it would have still worked but you know
the fact that she's six sixteen the fact
that she is doing something so reckless
and some people will claim that the
takeaway message is completely change
yourself and throw your life away for
the sake of love again I don't really
feel that that's it because I do I do
stand by my interpretation that air is
just the tipping point but I get where
some people get you know get frustrated
with that for me the problem is at the
end it has to do with the final
confrontation with Ursula now Ariel has
to be saved by other characters twice in
rapid succession initially by your
father and then by Erik now Disney
Princess is needing to get rescued
that's not exactly new I mean that's
kind of goes back to the beginning of
Disney you know Snow White Sleeping
Beauty even though more recent stuff
Jasmine had to be rescued in Aladdin you
know this it's it's all over the place
and Cinderella you know got saved by the
mice but there's a difference here
versus those other instances of
princesses being saved which is that all
of those other ones have the
circumstances that they needed to be
saved from sort of thrust upon them
usually by the villain here while Ursula
has certainly manipulated and taken
advantage of Ariel Ariel's
choices her relatively well informed
choices are what sparked this whole
thing off so she's in a situation of her
own making and
she really has absolutely no part in
getting herself out of it and that I do
think is a problem the biggest part that
she has in defeating Ursula is yanking
Ursula's hair back
um when she's getting ready to blast
Eric so that she ends up hitting her pet
eels instead and that's certainly
helpful and if you want to make the
argument like backtrack the fact that
Eric ultimately is the one who kills
Ursula that he wouldn't been able to do
that if Arielle hadn't saved him yes but
that's there's still enough left in the
final confrontation that Arielle has
absolutely no part in that I feel like
that's just it's not enough so Ursula
uses the power of the tried she gets
huge its iconic it's amazing and she
just starts taking potshots at Arielle
and getting ready to completely wipe her
out and Eric being a sailor well it well
established as a skill we know he can do
this gets on board a what happened a
sunken ship that Ursula has raised and
steers it so that the masthead skewers
her and she dies it's actually really
awesome ville and death one of the more
brutal ones too but Ariel takes
absolutely no part in that and it's not
that I would have expected Ariel to get
on the ship and actually be the one to
run Ursula through but just something
some acknowledgement some part of it
like off the top of my head what I tend
to think is if Ariel could have noticed
what Eric was doing and stalled or
distracted Ursula in some way you know
taunted her to buy a little time and
make sure focus was on her and she
doesn't see what's coming even that
would have been something it would have
made her an active instead of a passive
participant in the defeating of the
villain because there's something
incredibly frustrating about a character
making choices that endanger herself
her father her love interest her friends
and she doesn't fix it somebody else
does she comes in and through a desire
to fill her own wishes breaks everything
and somebody else comes in and just buys
new stuff I I do feel that Arielle does
still grow as a character she does learn
lessons but like the fact that the level
of endangerment she puts herself and
those around her in the fact that
there's basically no consequences to
that and she's rescued out of it by it
you know not that this is the problem
but it doesn't help two guys you know
daddy and then boyfriend it's it's
really unbelievable isn't an action hero
she's an emotional hero but just some
part some relevance in it because it's
become one of those things that sours my
rewatch a little bit watching her just
stare up at Ursula all waiting to get
killed I mean yes she dodges a couple
but at the very end she's just waiting
to get obliterated until Eric saves her
and I feel it's a shame just some part
so that she's she doesn't just lose any
participation in the conclusion now I do
think the movie bounces back after that
because the emotional resonance of what
happens between her and her father at
the very end rings incredibly true and I
think pulls the whole movie out of what
could have otherwise been a spiral
because Ursula was not the only conflict
the other conflict was Ariel and her
and her father and that one is between
her edge does focus on her and what she
helped him realize about her is what
drives his decision to grant her being
human so even though she's not active in
the sense of it's not like she begs him
and he finally gives in what she has
done and shown and demonstrated to him
through her actions does drive that
final resolution of the other major
conflict and I do feel that that saves
the movie and that's why this is a
nitpick grant instead of being a good
movie bad ending but yeah and and like I
said it annoys me there's I can't say
that it's still my favorite Disney movie
but it is my nostalgic favorite it is
the one that I like the most as a kid
there's no question about that and sort
of having this on it it's frustrating
any case Ariel and her lack of
participation in defeating the villain
in the Little Mermaid frustrates the
heck out of me taken that much to just
get her there and make er active and
they didn't do it and it's one aspect of
another wise amazing film it just drives
me a little bit nuts so what are your
thoughts on this whatever they are or if
you want to share another Disney
animated film that you've got a nitpick
on that works to draw something down the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff to do down there cuz buttons
and links ones at the patreon help us
appreciate it plus a whole bunch of
other stuff check it out see what I've
got going on or if you don't want to
that's okay too because at the end of
the day you're the counting soul
I'm just running the meetings until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]